the big moment is at hand the one
announcement every movie fan motion
picture exhibitor and at least five
producers are eagerly awaited the best
picture of the year to present this
award we call on an Oscar winner who has
long been an international screen
favorite and who has done as much for
the top hat and white tie as Marlon
Brando has done for mumbling here is mr.
Fred Astaire
bread the world awaits the pleasure of
your company thank you very much Bob but
first may I congratulate you on the
superb job you've done again tonight
thanks but I've already
Thank You Fred but I've already sent
myself a wire
I know who my friends are
now the nominees for the best picture of
1961 are Fanny Mansfield production
Warner Brothers produced by Joshua Logan
the Guns of Navarone Carl Foreman
production Columbia produced by car
Foreman The Hustler
Robert Rossum production 20th Century
Fox produced by Robert Rossum judgment
of nürnberg Stanley Kramer production
United Artists reduced by Stanley Kramer
West Side Story nourished pictures
incorporated and B and P enterprises
incorporated United Artists produced by
Robert Wise mr. Miller to please the
winner is west side salt
thank you very much it's been a
wonderfully exciting evening from West
Side Story and I'm naturally grateful
for at all I want to express my
appreciation to the Maurice cop named
particular Harold Harold Mary she was so
much help and such a sturdy aide to me
and making the picture and I want to pay
special tribute to the men who are
responsible really for West Side Story
being on the screen about talking about
those who created the original wonderful
stage show Jerry Robbins Leonard
Bernstein Steve Sondheim and Arthur
Lawrence all of us who had anything to
do with putting West Side Story on the
screen considered ourselves very
fortunate to have their wonderful
material to to work with thank you very
much
but hope we'll be back in a moment